shirk their responsibility of voting in
person let's talk about what's going on
in this here country we got the story
from npr from wamu biden criticizes
ultra maga republicans as inflation
rises so basically he does the speech
and he's like look there's two reasons
for inflation the unprecedented pandemic
it's like i can give you some i can give
you that right putin's war
inflation was happening before putin's
war but it maybe kicked it up a little
bit then with food costs and everything
and then he goes on to say but the ultra
mega have no solution they're going to
raise your taxes cut your pay and make
all the problems and i'm like dude the
ultra mega like was three years of
prosperity the best numbers of our lives
so saith jim cramer and then the
pandemic happened and things got kind of
wonky so i'll give that to joe biden
when he's like the pandemic caused us
problems sure
but you know i mentioned it earlier
a year ago i was like guys
food shortages are coming it's gonna get
bad
if dude on internet complaining can talk
about the food shortages and the
president could not do anything to plan
for or alleviate this then either he is
completely incapable of doing anything
about it and he should probably probably
say that i can't do anything sorry
you're out of food or he just didn't do
what he could have done because he's
incompetent and he could have done
something about it now let me show you
what we're dealing with
gas prices at record highs
perhaps when you have gas prices setting
records you shouldn't shut down
pipelines and you shouldn't ban fracking
but you know this is the game he's
played he's he he was very happy to help
russia's
gas pipeline pre-war
meanwhile shutting down the keystone xl
and banning fracking on public lands and
then he says nothing i did caused this
and it's like well at least a little bit
dude come on take some responsibility
now you have this story from the ap
parents hunting for baby formula as
shortage spans us
so this is becoming a very serious issue
i can only say this
if the president is completely incapable
of doing anything about this then he
needs to come out and tell the american
people he should have told him a year
ago there is no policy and nothing i can
do to help you have a nice day of course
he wouldn't because it's not true the
reality is joe biden is just really bad
at what he does well and also if there's
nothing they can do about it they at
least have a responsibility to try to
warn the american people so that they
can prepare on their own i understand
that's difficult because there's an
argument to be made certain people are
going to start panicking but people
should at least know so that they have a
fighting chance i just think it's funny
that
when i do the shout outs for safe and
ready meals the emergency food stuff
which is like you know it's been kind of
a lot in these past several months
it is a weird phenomena among urban
liberals where they mock the idea of
buying emergency supplies
and now how many of them are going to
the store and they're like oh there's no
food
no food
what do you do i get really bothered
when they blame the pandemic for this
stuff and they because i feel like it
was the response to the pandemic however
you wanted to define that the response
to the virus the shutdown that really
caused this not the virus itself people
responded in a way where they shut down
businesses across the world for like a
year a year or something crazy and yep
and now bill gates has come out and
reversed the entirety of his position
bill gates is spreading dangerous
disinformation
that you are not allowed to say on
youtube that's right bill gates claimed
can you believe this that kovit is like
the flu
no bill gates youtube will ban you if
you say that ultra magic you got to him
yeah
what if bill gates did just walk out one
day with like a hat on and he was like
i've been convinced guys yeah that's it
it took me some time red pill gates yeah
he's with his tailgates he's back well
this is it's so typical though right
because
all right so for a very long time the
left's argument was if you cut even one
penny of social welfare spending people
are going to die you monster and then
they said yeah we could just shut down
the entire economy for like a year and a
half that'll be fine no one's going to
get hurt if we do that well now we're
starting to see in a much more plain way
the ramifications of that and it's going
to get really ugly and they're never
going to take responsibility for this
they're going to claim that this was
just because of covet and ignore the
fact that it was their insane
disproportionate response to it which
failed to take into account the
unintended consequences it's just funny
i'm imagining you know joe biden
answering for all of the failures of his
presidency and at first he's like
impassioned like look you know it was
coven you know on president coveton by
the time you get to like the 87th
failure he's like uh that one was um
gnomes i guess i don't know somebody
somebody stole my socks
i slipped in the shower man slipped in
the shower major biden's fault yeah a
major bite yeah he's slipped in the
shower
i mean this is i just want to mention
this is and it's insane to even have to
explain this right but this is
a consequence of putting people in
charge of making decisions who will pay
literally no price if those decisions
turn out to be a disaster for somebody
else or if the effects of those
decisions turn out to be a disaster for
everybody else look where we are
matthew is just explaining how these
democrats offices are all closed
they're they're literally on vacation
not doing their jobs how much do you
want to bet people like swalwell he's
like
he's going to be like a capital grill in
dc or something like ruth's chris
steakhouse
and then you know he's talking and
they're laughing and he's like he's like
wait another bottle of the dom please
and then his phone go his watch goes
burn and he goes oh i better tweet so
people think that i'm actually involved
in politics uh republicans want to ban
interracial marriage scent anyway
oh yeah
yeah firing off a banger like they're
checked out dude what a hot take they're
all checked out i have a great example
of that actually the sean patrick
maloney who's a democrat in new york who
chairs the house democrats campaign
committee he was he went to france for
va for a wedding at a billionaire
chateau
and while he was there he said mask up
we're all in this together we have to
defeat the virus he's literally partying
maskless at a french billionaire's
chateau defying a state department
travel warning against going to france
brilliant this is this is literally
liberal governance is you know it's the
classic rules for me but not for the but
i you know one of the sort of story
lines that i covered a lot was democrat
mass mandate hypocrisy because there are
never ending examples of this but this
is one of the most ridiculous i'd give a
shout out to ted cruz when that freeze
happened then he gets on a plane to go
fly to where was he going
and he was like oh is my daughter's my
daughter i i would have respected it
what he did if he just owned up to it
and said i'm going on vacation like and
you know
that's it that's happening have a nice
day instead he made it seem like oh oh
you know just just like own it dude you
know look if you want to go on vacation
i got no problem with that
what do you think your federally elected
representative is going to do for the
for these local issues i certainly think
it would have been better if he was
there for his constituents but i think
the bigger issue i have with him is
republicans aren't the ones screaming
about you wearing masks and not
traveling it's the left who is saying
you know travel is should be restricted
and you should wear a mask and do all
these things so when gavin newsom says
everybody has to wear a mask and then
goes to that you know french restaurant
not wearing a mask we're like hypocrite
when ted cruz is like i'm going if he
was just like i'm going on vacation i'd
be like oh okay well i guess sure
instead he's just like oh or it was my
daughter's and i'm coming back
you make me think about how you were
just talking before the show about the
um what was it the crack kits oh the
biden crack pipes yeah biden
administration buy about these like safe
usage kits or whatever they're called
specifically and safe smoking and then
they were like oh there's crack pipes in
these safe smoking kits and they're like
no biden's administration is like no
there's no crack pipes but there were
and then and then what happened was
behind the scenes like quick get rid of
the crack pipes yeah and the people like
well if there's not crack wipes then
it's not a safe smoking kit because
they're gonna end up using aluminum
they're supposed to be crack pipes in
there why are there no crack pipes turns
out they were all along and they just
lied just like ted cruz on vacation like
you don't need to lie to save face here
we're all in this together maybe
maybe sometimes but i think they do look
look ted cruz going on vacation is not
that big of a deal it was a national
news story i i it might it might look if
i was and i like the representative and
there's a disaster in my district i
wouldn't go to cancun
but him going on vacation it's kind of
like well that's kind of a you know
stupid thing to do i guess that's about
it
when they realized giving out crack
pipes was like not a popular thing to do
they just lied and said no or not and
you're like safe smoking kids have crack
raps no they don't
they literally no they don't and then
the best part was when these left-wing
groups when they said there's no crack
pipes left-wing groups came out and they
were like why are you taking the crack
bikes
and i'm just like dude if they came out
and said yes there are crack pipes in
the crack safe smoking kits why because
they're clean and we're trying to limit
the spread of disease
then when someone says don't you think
supplying these could increase the
amount of like increase the likelihood
someone does smoke crack the answer is
it could i guess
i want to touch on that though for a
second so these are government-funded
crack pipes and um one of them so i went
to three locations one in dc one in
baltimore and one in richmond none of
them have any effort at
prevention of saying you know maybe
don't do this the richmond one actually
when we went there uh with my colleague
he and i got there uh it was a van in
the in a hotel parking lot and they saw
two of us walking up and they said well
we we only have one more crack pipe but
we can give you guys
meth pipes and also cocaine snorting
kits and we said
sure we will take these things like all
three and they gave us a brochure and
they said we're an organization
dedicated to ending the racist war on
drugs there was nothing about how you
know maybe you should not do this if
you're having a problem you should call
these numbers but the biden
administration yeah after we reported on
how these the blind administration was
funding crack pipes um they went all out
against the free beacon normally this
would be called an attack on the first
amendment attack on the free press and
then they colluded with fact checkers so
i'm actually way more black pilled on
fact checkers i think these are some of
the most useless people uh they
they're they're incredibly useful to the
regime yes correct
good point but they are some of the
worst they couldn't make it in real
journalism so all they do is regurgitate
talking points from the left to get
articles removed from social media i
don't think they're journalists yes
they're democrat operatives correct you
know it's like what what was it there
was um
desantis said something what was it it
was a fact check where he said oh yeah
60 of college debt is held by graduate
you know people with graduate degrees
and politifact said it was fake news
but the source from desantis was the
pointer institute which is like the
parent company of politics
and they were like he misunderstood we
we actually said something slightly
different and it was like i can't
remember exactly what they said
but desantis simplified the point which
they said mostly false this is what they
do the famous the famous line from
bernie and trump trump said something
like there's 50 unemployment in in the
inner city and they said mostly false
then bernie said the exact same thing
and said mostly true
yeah right uh maybe not and maybe mean
the same thing this actually also
happened with tom cotton when he wrote
that uh stimulus checks would be
received by the boston marathon bomber
uh the washington post ruled this false
and then after it was proven true that
literally dzhokhar tsarnaev received a
1400 stimmy they then said oh this is
still one pinocchio
wow like we know this is true so
cotton's office went back and said ah
it's still false thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there